ladies and gentlemen my name is ryan
wright and my name is jerry welcome to
the movie buff show or the movie buff
podcast whatever we feel like saying
that day is the title of the show
anyway what we're gonna do for you guys
today is we're gonna
talk about upcoming movies in february
2013.
2013. if there's any movies we missed we
apologize we were probably just not
interested in talking about that film
but anyway why don't we get the ball
rolling jerry let's get going with
february 1st the 1st of february
february 1st you know yeah february 1st
we're going to talk about bullet to the
head and a quick synopsis here a
bulleted ahead uh provided from coming
soon.net based on a graphic novel bullet
to the head tells the story of a new
orleans hitman stelvester stallone and a
dc cop uh played by sung kang who you
might know from the fast and the furious
uh series the asian guy from it
he's the main asian guy in tokyo drift
one of them
and he's also the main guy in fast and
fast five anywho they basically form an
alliance to bring down the killers of
their respective partners
and before we do that we're about to go
watch the trailer
wow
wow what a trailer movie looks like
ground beef it looks like a bee movie
yeah it just looks like an exploitation
movie yeah you know it actually doesn't
look that interesting to me to be honest
i i watching this trailer it just makes
me go
looks like this movie's been done one
too many times before how many action
movies are we gonna get where the badass
father
has a daughter who is kidnapped i mean
it happens in bad boys too
it happens and
live free or die hard and now it's
happening in bullet to the head taken
taken oh yeah there's taken that's what
the whole movie is about
it's it's a repetitive uh idea
and it doesn't look like there's
anything unique about it to offer you
know it just looks like typical violence
typical
action that all of it looks very
standard typical
yeah
the only the only things that really
nothing really grabs me about that
trailer i mean the axe fight kinda seems
like a cool idea i just don't get why
sly stallone is still doing uh these
stupid action films
he's an oscar-winning uh screenwriter
you know he won the oscar for rocky and
he's written some other good films too
and he's very much capable of
doing films that are above
these
silly action films it's like come on man
you already made your comeback now let's
see what else you can do besides playing
the old guy again who can still kick ass
maybe maybe he's trying to go away again
so that he can have a comeback again
yeah i'm like it was because of the
reason of your bad action movies why you
had a career that failed
it's time to change the game up stallone
it's time to change it up buddy alright
let's move on next up on the list on
february 1st is a movie i'm very very
very much looking forward to called warm
bodies a zombie film a very different
take on the zombie film and the plot
summary divided by i mean provided by
coming soon.net goes a funny new twist
on a classic love story warm bodies is a
poignant tale about the power of human
connection
after a zombie epidemic
r that's the letter r that's the
character's main name is the letter r a
highly unusual zombie encounters julie
who is a human survivor and r rescues
her from a zombie attack julie sees that
r is different from other zombies and as
the two form a special relationship and
their struggle for survival r becomes
increasingly more human setting off an
exciting romantic and often comical
chain of events that begins to transform
the other zombies and maybe even the
whole lifeless world let's watch the
trailer
i want to watch this movie so [ __ ]
bad this movie looks incredible man it
has it looks like a good time it looks
like everything's solid it looks like a
unique story a unique take on uh
on a familiar genre it's got a lot going
for it man the acting looks great the
story looks great all of it looks very
fun it looks like there's going to be
action in it as well
i you know looks like there will be
zombie violence as well too you know
it's going to be a good time it just
that's the best way to describe it a
good
time it looks romantic as hell too yeah
no i mean it looks you know you joke
about those movies that have a little
something for everyone but it really
does sort of look like a movie that
could
uh
maybe bridge the gap a little bit
in a way that like twilight could not
and i guess twilight was never meant to
but you know it could bridge the gap
between like you know
guys would be interested girls would be
interested you know even horror fans
might be interested regular moviegoers
might be interested you know it looks
like it's got a little something for
everyone you know the only the only the
only thing that worries me a little is
those uh is those cg effects but uh
but other than that man it looks it
looks like a great time and even though
it's a zombie film it's pg-13 it is a
pg-13 zombie film which might make
people a little bit weary just because
it's like zombie pg-13 come on guys
when you see this yeah for this movie
particularly it doesn't seem like it's
necessary to be r-rated i could totally
see how you can make this a really good
promising pg-13 zombie film yeah plus uh
you know dave franco's in it
yeah no it's uh it's over it's all about
the franco the franco brothers man
moving on moving on moving on uh coming
out february 8th identity thief
identity thief oh boy
ooh i'm excited for this one sort of not
really
um why don't we go ahead and watch the
trailer for it
huh
it looks funny
it looks like i'll laugh a couple times
yeah
it kind of
i'm wondering i'm still sort of because
it's like uh the it's from the director
of horrible bosses and horrible bosses
was one of those movies that snuck up on
me and then all of a sudden it was
really funny
so now it's like all right it's your
second big comedy like let's see what
you got and uh it looks like it has that
sort of edge that
uh horrible bosses has i don't know if
i'm if i can say i'm excited for it but
um yeah it could be fun
basically if you guys don't know what
it's about identity thief is uh jason
bateman is a man who's a victim of
identity thief his name is sandy and the
person who steals his identity is
actually a female named sandy played by
melissa mccarthy so i'm sure we'll get a
few laughs of you know jason bateman
with his deadpan hilarious
comedy that he does and with melissa
mccarthy doing her
zany type of slapstick physical comedy
that she's got going on for being a big
woman
so i'm sure it's gonna be i'm sure
there's gonna be a few good laughs you
know horrible bosses surprised me it
didn't look that funny to me but i
checked it out and i was laughing the
whole time and to see that jason
bateman's the star of this and seth
gordon the director of horrible bosses
is directing this it actually gets me a
little excited and also you know john
favreau is in it amanda pete's in it
robert patrick is in it john cho is also
in it so they've got a lot of people in
it who i actually do enjoy watching on
the screen
i'm sure there's going to be something
in here that is enjoyable it doesn't
look like a great comedy it doesn't look
like a bad comedy it looks like you
you'll have a few good laughs and you
might enjoy yourself and plus there's
nothing really else coming out on that
day so it looks kind of like due date to
me i get a due date vibe from it oh yeah
definitely yeah you're completely right
about that now so you know i i might
check it out it's one of those because
because seth gordon's an interesting
director because he's done a couple like
documentaries i've heard her really good
um and you know he's done a lot of
episodes of a lot of funny tv shows so
you know i'm not rushing out to see it
but i'm interested okay you have my
attention
okay let's move on february 8th
is uh also having a movie side effects
is having side effects come out wow
side effects steven soderbergh making a
movie every like four months now all
right let's check out the trailer for
side effects
okay
so the trailer's not exactly clear on
what's going on yeah
well from what it seems like
i guess
uh jude law is a therapist or here's
here's a plot right here
side effects is a provocative thriller
about emily and martin emily being
played by rooney mara who i think is
absolutely beautiful and channing tatum
who is as equally absolutely beautiful a
successful new york they are a
successful new york couple whose world
unravels when a new drug prescribed by
emily psychiatrist jude law
which is intended to treat anxiety has
unexpected side effects and it does look
like a psychological thriller like even
though i can't really tell what's going
on in the trailer and what's necessarily
wrong with everything that's happening
like the side effects that are occurring
it's it's got a lot of that subtle
undertones about it that contagion seems
to to contain
yeah you know it is soderberg and
soderbergh did contagion and
it looks like it has a similar type of
creepy effect going on where it really
is more of a psychological thriller and
when psychological throws are pulled off
well they can be very enticing yeah no
and it's also from the um you know the
writer's got some some stuff under his
belt because it is the same writer as
contagion and uh the informant which was
another sodenberg movie but it's also he
co-wrote the born ultimatum oh really so
uh yeah he's so he's got some might be a
good movie then action-packed throw
rides under his belt and uh i heard they
are hiring him to write dawn of the
planet of the apes
so it says and i like rise of the planet
of the apes a lot so if they're putting
their faith and trust in him in uh the
sequel to that i'm sure we'll probably
get something here that seems really
good it looks like a good valentine's
day movie
where couples are having a very hard
time getting along it's rated r for a
lot of things that sound very
interesting
sexuality nudity i hope you see rudy mar
naked please
please please please
violence and language so
i'm sure basically the big four the big
four right the big four things that
things can be rated looks like catherine
zeta jones is really making movies again
and she's in it as well
and she's coming out in january with
broken city and now this one as well so
let's see yeah man her people must be
really really pushing her now because
she she went away from work for years
yeah now she back so good for her and
it's closing excellent all right moving
on moving on let's see here they're
releasing top gun they are if you
haven't seen top gun go check it out
or
wait till february 8th to watch it in
imax 3d yeah that's all we'll pretty
much say about that february 14th tony
scott
february 14th a good day to die hard oh
yeah there's always a good day to die
hard and we're gonna go watch the
trailer and we'll be right back to tell
you our opinion of what we think
wow
yes yes yes a thousand times yes can not
wait to go watch a good day to die hard
out of a lot of the trailers that i have
seen for february this by far looks like
a damn good time it's got back the good
old john mcclane yippie kaye mother
russia
and he's gonna be
it you know what i love too in a day and
age where americans don't seem to
respect america
it's going to a movie where it's like
this is what it means to be an american
a badass american
what's the kill house just to kill
russia just a [ __ ] rush no no i don't
mean it like that it just
john mclean is such like uh it's there's
something about die hard that seems to
embrace american pride because the
villains are always some type of
terrorist who really does not like
america except for a live free or die
hard where the villains were american
but in this particular one it go it just
goes back to that simple terrorist john
mcclane wrong place at the wrong time
but he's gonna go save the world anyway
and it's got everything in it it's got
comedy it's got a shitload of action it
looks like it had a great shot at the
end it looks like just a really fun
fun
action-filled time one hell of an
adventure and i'm sure there'll be some
great father-son chemistry between bruce
willis and jai courtney
yeah
yeah i don't have much else to say
besides that i mean uh
i'm i guess i'm a little less excited
than you just because like i didn't grow
up on stuff like die hard so i don't
have like the connection but it looks
like a good time man and that helicopter
shot
like jeez who's that girl that takes off
her jacket on that motorcycle wow she's
hot yeah random hit girl yeah no i'm i'm
i gotta go catch up on some of the
diehard sequels but uh but uh it looks
like a good time i'm i'm excited i'm a
little excited and it brings it back to
rated r rating which is what's you know
i like live free or die hard even though
it's pg-13 i still enjoyed it and this
brings it back to the r rating which i'm
sure a lot of die-hard fans will be very
much satisfied with this could be the
final entry in it uh i doubt it if it
makes money and it will not be the final
trick yeah maybe as long as bruce willis
is alive there will still be die hard i
gotta say out of all the old action
stars bruce willis seems to be the least
distracting old guy in it yeah it could
well because he at least comes out every
now and again and does something else it
seems like he's he's not only is he's
the most talented actor of the bunch
well yeah it doesn't feel like he's
milking it so to speak it doesn't feel
like that's the only thing he has or the
only reason people want to watch him
you know um because i mean looper has
action elements but it's like you know
he did looper and looper's like a story
about character oh yeah he gives a real
performance in that yeah so you know he
takes different kinds of movies so i
think he's he's a little more
i was just wondering this yesterday when
i when i went to see gangster squad
because like there were bruce willis
posters everywhere i was like
bruce willis has kind of been around
forever
and he's like really big again but i
can't remember a time where he wasn't
around and wasn't at least somewhat big
so like yeah that's what i mean is bruce
willis has always had a career he didn't
really need to make a comeback yeah
exactly it seems like whenever he
appears in an expendables movie it's
like he's helping them out yeah
because he's the only one that really
sustained a career throughout all of
this yeah all right moving on the list
an animated film
escape from planet earth brought by the
weinstein company
from the people that made ie doesn't say
what they've made
but basically here's a plot synopsis of
it it's a three-day 3d animated family
comedy that catapults moviegoers to
planet dab where admired astronauts
scorched supernova played by brendan
frazier isn't he where's he been yeah
just making kids movies lately he's a
national hero to the blue alien
population a master of daring rescue
scorch pulls off astonishing feats with
the quiet aid of his nerdy by the rules
brother gary played by rob quadri cadre
sorry
head of mission control at basa
get it it's not nasa it's bassa when
bassa's known nonsense chief lena played
by jessica alba informs the brothers of
an sos from a notoriously dangerous
planet scorch rejects gary's warnings
and bounds off for yet another exciting
mission but when scorch finds himself
caught in a friendship trap set by the
evil shanker played by fat guy james
gandolfini it's such a scrawny risk
adverse i don't know how to say fat guy
it's up to scrawny risk at verse gary to
do the real rescuing as the inter
planetary stakes rise to new heights
gary is left to save his brother his
planet his beloved wife kira played by
sarah jessica parker and their adventure
hungry son kip that is a long
explanation it's a long yeah it's a long
one basically uh they have to go rest
and aliens have to go rescue someone
from planet earth that's all they have
to go say all they have to go say it's
got a lot of people in it's got craig
robinson george lopez sophia vergara
steve zahn chris parnell brandon frazier
rob cordrey jessica alba sarah jessica
parker and the very famous william
shatner and paul rubin's pee-wee is in
it oh very nice let's take a look at the
trailer people
so escape from planet earth looks like a
dreamworks movie in a lot of ways to me
but it actually looks like a fun time
it's got a different take on the whole
alien it's not an alien invasion movie
uh it's i like the idea of an alien
coming to earth because you know they
they hear about it and then we capture
them and they have to rest and
like the humans are the bad guys in a
way
rather than cartoony or district nine
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly and
and it looks like there will be a lot of
fun interesting characters you know i
like the idea of how they go to area 51
and you get to see some like a weird
type of mouse i think or some three-eyed
creatures it just looks like it would be
a really fun time you know i like one of
my favorite pixar movies is monsters inc
because i like the whole world of a
whole bunch of different types of
creatures and i feel like this movie
will provide us with several different
types of creatures as well
which i'm actually looking forward to
and uh just knowing that craig
robinson's in it kind of gets me excited
yeah i mean it's definitely got a good
cast and i mean these these movies don't
ever seem remiss for a good cast but um
it could be fun i'm always a little
weary of movies like this um
you know just i guess because we're
spoiled on you know pixar and recent
dreamworks yeah definitely um
but you know it's it's um
uh yeah you know i'm i'm i'm slightly
interested in it i mean
i haven't seen hoodwinked or hardware ii
which is what the other guys uh the
writers
of those movies wrote this
um i heard good stuff about at least the
first hoodwinked so yeah i don't think
anyone saw hoodwink part two
yeah no i i didn't i heard yeah okay all
right well
moving on coming out february 22nd 2013
i am very excited to watch this one
it's a sci-fi horror thriller yeah i
love just the premise the title to me
doesn't seem to match what the trailer
is
but oh wait
the title to me doesn't seem to match
what the trailer is
but we'll take one last look at the
trailer here we go
yeah this definitely looks [ __ ] scary
yeah this looks like a cool flick i mean
it's from blumhouse and i i love what
they do i mean you know the the studio
that uh
brought to you of course paranormal
activity but also oh they didn't just do
you know paranormal like oh no they're
like insidious
yeah they're doing lords of salem uh you
know a zombie's new movie yeah okay so
um you know they're they're kind of
uh masters of the micro budget you know
spook house flicks and so i'm excited
for this i mean their name is enough to
get me in because they seem
they seem to be like you know actually
into the art so they know how to make
they take these premises that we've
heard before you know like oh family in
a home and then there's a haunting going
on because that's technically what
paranormal activity insidious is but
they know how to bring a lot of
different takes to it and this is
similar uh the plot to it is as the
barrett family's peaceful suburban life
is rocked by an escalating series of
disturbing events they come to learn
that a terrifying and deadly force is
after them and you know what it looks
like good acting a lot of really good
acting in it carrie russell's in it and
she's always solid jk simmons is in it
and he's always solid there's a lot of
people in it that look like it's gonna
be a really good film i i i have a lot
of faith in this one well and see that's
the thing about bloomhouse that i like
so much uh blumhouse is uh because they
they seem to get these interesting
directors and they they always assemble
an interesting cast you know full of
very you know capable actors you know
who you wouldn't necessarily think as
being in a horror film you know so they
they really you know
they're just making movies they're
making like actual movies and uh you
know
like i said except for the the
paranormal activity movies which are a
bit different on those regards you know
i
i always uh take a look at what they're
up to and this looks like it could be
really cool and really unsettling it
looks like the you know bringing i think
they brought a good director on board
for it he's actually the writer of it
scott charles stewart who's mainly done
visual effects and just to list off a
few that he's really credited for mars
attacks uh jurassic park the lost world
sin city harry potter and the goblet of
fire the host superman returns parts of
the caribbean too not at the museum
grindhouse pirates three live free or
die hard blade runner iron man and a
movie called red cliff that i've never
heard of
but you don't mess with the zone
the most expensive comedy ever made
so basically this guy's a visual effects
director and it's always interesting
when you hear about a visual effects guy
well he has done movies yeah he's done
he did he did this is the only part that
slightly worries me is he did legion and
priest which
you know weren't so well received
although i i have heard that at least
his you know the visuals on those were
really cool those are two movies yeah
but who knows maybe his thermal won't be
a charm you know sometimes you gotta get
your feet wet before you finally make a
good movie well what i think is cool too
is that you know i mean uh they do
blumhouse you know they do a lot of
micro budget stuff you know uh so i
think taking him out of these big
effects extravagant extravaganzas and
putting him into
you know giving him a shot with the
script he wrote it's not based on a
graphic novel it doesn't seem like you
know giving him a small budget movie
with his own script i think could be
really cool oh yeah absolutely just let
his mind go a little bit wild yeah
because i think sometimes you got to
take the money away to to make to give
people something different to work with
in a different yeah because sometimes
when you uh give them a smaller
production budget they it requires the
artist mentality to come out and go how
can i be more creative to make this work
yeah exactly and i like how jk simmons
is in it as you know they always have
that one character who they're like we
need to find someone who knows about
this and jk simmons comes in but instead
of giving them hope he's like no you
guys are all gonna die
yeah i know how this works
it's over yeah you're gonna be taken by
then
there was no point in hiring me but
anyway uh moving on dark skies comes out
february 22nd
2013. i will be there i will definitely
be there too and the other movie coming
out that day is a film starring dwayne
the rock johnson oh called snitch an
action thriller dwayne johnson
and susan sarandon yeah dude if you've
been wait if you've been waiting to see
these two giants of the cinema
screen together at the same time this is
your day
yes two mega action stars coming
together dwayne the rock johnson and
susan sarandon hey john bernthal is in
it for the walking dead oh that's
exciting well anyway if you guys don't
know the plot to it it's about a father
who goes undercover for the dea in order
to free his son who was imprisoned after
being set up in a drug deal
some houses and surrounding comes into
this i've never seen the trailer before
i actually i walked in during this
trailer at zero dark thirties so this is
gonna be a little bit of a surprise for
the both of us ooh perfect here we go
snitch not not snatch not guy richie
no snitch
yeah
they should have called this movie
tattletail snitches and talkers get
stitches and walkers
because people break their legs
for snitching
snitch snitch okay so seeing the trailer
for this movie
um
at first i was a little distracted to
see that okay this is based on a true
story
this is a father this is the buffest
father i have ever seen
and yeah there's construction kind of a
break yeah but
still he's he's remarkably buff
um
you would expect like an action-packed
thing when you first hear about it
especially it's called snitch and
everything
you might expect a lot of thrills but it
looks more like it's a drama with a few
scenes of violence in it it doesn't
necessarily look like it's jam-packed or
loaded with action throughout which is
fine
well it looks like it has a fair amount
at least i mean it looks like it's like
it's like a gritty crime thriller you
know yeah yeah and you know what i gotta
say it looks like
the rock isn't as laughable as he used
to be many years ago he gets he's been
getting better throughout the years yeah
i he really started getting a lot more
respect with acne when he when he
started doing more comedies because
people saw he had a real comedic touch
yeah and this one requires him to do
like some real drama going on and i was
actually buying it in the trailer yeah
no this actually looks cool
yeah and and and i'm actually kind of
interested to see it now i mean
uh it looks like it could be a thrilling
you know
action-packed story you know with with a
bit more of a serious tone and i
actually the cast looks good i mean
everybody seems to
it's weird to hear like susan sarandon
and the rock and barry pepper and
benjamin brown but then you see them all
it's like oh it makes sense yeah like so
i'm i'm i'm interested i'm interested in
this film
what what bothers me though is like i'm
i'm a little bit worried
because it says it's based on a true
story or inspired by true events
and
when with films like this
it tends to be like the director doesn't
know what he wants to usually do a lot
of the time does he want to tell the
true story or does he want to make an
action flick does he want to make a
thrilling picture what does he want to
do yeah and it looks because the trailer
starts off like for most of it it's just
a drama like a thrilling drama and then
it like escapes off into you know the
rocks territory where it's a lot more
action going on and as much as it
doesn't want to be called the rock i'm
probably still going to be calling him
the rock for as long as i'm alive yeah
but anyway he's he's back with this film
and it looks
decent actually i'm probably going to go
check it out i have to go check it out
so it's
one of the writers of uh
of the lone ranger and revolutionary
road oh okay and uh who's the other then
the other guy is also the director the
other writer who's uh comes from a stunt
background a heavy stunt background
um so i it could be interesting uh the
the writer uh co-writer director rick
roman
i'm not 100 sure how to say his name so
if you're listening sir i'm sorry uh but
yeah he's got a heavy stunt background
he's directed a few things i think this
is probably the biggest of them what
would you say is the movie you're
looking forward to the most this month i
mean this upcoming month
um for me it's warm bodies and a good
day to die hard
uh yeah warm bodies is probably the one
that looks like the most fun and um and
dark skies just because i'm i'm a big
horror fan i like sci-fi and it's you
know
from a from a brand i i am big into so
i'm just based on those things alone i'm
pretty interested in dark skies so
probably yeah warm bodies and dark skies
are the most interesting to me well
hopefully february delivers on some of
their awesome trailers hopefully bullet
to the head is better than what the
trailer looks like so
let's see let's see anyway guys thank
you for listening this is the movie buff
podcast talking about upcoming movies
february 2013 upcoming films we will be
back to talk about uh upcoming movies in
march 2013 so make sure to check us out
there and in the meantime if you haven't
heard it yet
we will be back for march 2013 upcoming
movies march 2013 to talk about that
yeah tune in in a month which they have
a few movies coming out there uh you
know they got like jack the giant slayer
last exorcism part two oz great and the
powerful so on and so forth there's
gonna be a lot of films coming out don't
don't give away the ending before we
record the show i know i'm just getting
a little teased just a little tease all
right a little tease yeah yeah just a
little bit to to to wet your appetite
yeah yeah so basically uh check us out
then and in the meantime you can check
out all of our other videos at the real
rejects channel r-e-e-l get it i'm sure
no one you know of has ever done that
before yeah
no one's ever used the word real
well anyway guys we've had a great time
talking i hope you guys enjoyed it too
we'll
not see you we will speak
with you next time speak with you next
time have a good night or a good day to
you bye bye